Hi everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at the outline for this
series of courses. And then we're also going to take a look at profiling. So let's get
started.
So first up, we'll talk about profiling concepts. From there, we'll look at types of rendering.
We'll also look at concepts of thread profiling, how that works, calling concepts, calling methods,
GPU visualizer, GPU draw thread, the CPU draw thread and how that plays, as well as the
analyzing of draw calls in general, and looking at Unreal Insights. We'll then take a look
at optimization visualizers. We'll look at using visualizers, some quick notes on those,
and also a review of Lumen, Nanite and Virtual Shadow map visualizers, which we've covered
in other classes. And then we'll also look at a few pro tips and some secret little visualizers
that you can use to help with your workflow.
Next we'll look at Nanite and Virtual Shadows. Why use Nanite? Using it and Virtual Shadow
maps overview. We'll also look at a review of understanding LODs. Now again, I say review
because some of these are covered in your other classes. We'll look at editing and using
LODs, LOD colorization, using poly edit tools, swapping geo, merging geo and HLOTs and how
that works. And finally we'll end with review of texture material optimization, texture
optimization and material optimization when it comes to working with Unreal. Alright,
let's go and get started. Optimization for linear content, profiling geometry, we're
going to take a look now at profiling concepts. So some of the things you want to look at
is a pros and cons when it comes to the types of rendering. There's forward rendering and
that is your typical use or at least in the past that is used to create a VR scenario
because it was a little bit lighter, but unfortunately you would have some limitations on the type
of light that you would use, which would make things a little bit trickier. The overhead
or the idea behind it was that things could be a little bit lighter so you weren't using
the full capacity of all the things in the engine, but you're using just enough to be
able to create a nice, efficient VR scenario. There's also deferred rendering. So deferred
rendering is the old school way in which Unreal would bake your lighting. You would be fast,
is especially in small, medium scenes, and had lower realism compared to ray tracing
in Lumen. And it's largely a 2D operation. Calculates lighting with approximations is
complex to use. Now you'll notice in the first one forward, it says a number of features
are not yet supported, but you don't have to worry about that so much now. You can actually
use VR or build things in VR using Lumen. Lumen now supports VR, so you don't have to
actually set things in your project settings for forward rendering, which is kind of convenient.
So looking at ray tracing in Lumen, this is suited for complex effects, GI reflection,
refraction, and soft shadows. Now refraction is limited. You won't get the same as you
would with ray tracing. You'll have to fake some of it, but there will be some ability
that you have in here to simulate some of those options. But again, full caustics and
refraction, you're going to get from Path Tracer. It's easy to implement when it comes
to ray tracing in Lumen. It's more intuitive, reliable, realistic, and mimics light's behavior.
Only Lumen is optimized though, keep in mind to be able to be used with ICV effects. Ray
tracing leans more towards final pixel. That's because it takes a pretty big hit on your
GPU. Now Path Tracing is not suited for real time. It is not real time, or at least the
idea of real time was not in mind when it was created. It's for rendering final pixel
projects. Displays a more accurate light refraction and caustic effect, takes longer to render
than ray tracing in Lumen due to sample settings used for better quality, and renders each frame
independently. It isn't like previous renders, such as ray tracing in Lumen, where if you
rendered it in the movie render queue, it typically will reference the previous frame
to be able to make the new one. Path Tracer is a bit different, so you have to keep those
things in mind and test things out as you go. Now again, that's for another class when
we talk about path tracing, and we get into that in our ray tracing and path tracing courses.
So when to use them? Again, as I said before, rasterization forward is mainly used for AR
and VR, because it's dumbed down to be able to make things work a little bit more efficiently.
Rasterization or deferred baking lights, this one can be used in your typical game scenario
if you need, and can be used for virtual production if needed. Ray tracing also can be used for
virtual production, but it's mainly its focus is on final pixel, such as with movies and
so forth. Now we do have some of our ray tracing clients, such as automotive and architecture
that will use ray tracing quite often. But again, a lot of the times it's not necessarily
for interaction, although it can be used for interaction, you just have to optimize your
materials and your items in your scene accordingly, so you get the best frame rate that you possibly
can. Lumen is one of the more efficient ways to be able to work, and is now unreal out
of the box. As soon as you fire up unreal, you'll see that Lumen is working, and you'll
go in there and be able to check off some of the things to make it work appropriately.
We go into that into another class, when we talk about lighting optimization. But for
the most part, it is ready for ICVFX, and also games, as well as final pixel. Path tracing,
like we said before, is mainly for final pixel made for film and TV. And you can keep that
focus using it, because it really does give you some high realistic refractions and cost
basics, and it's really great to use. So let's go and take a look here at draw calls
for a moment. So draw calls here are very important to consider. A package of triangles,
and what it is, is a package of triangles being sent to the GPU. The GPU renders draw
calls by draw call, not triangle by triangle. So in other words, each mesh material is a
different draw call. So as you see here down below on this example, you'll see that this
skydome is a draw call. This piece of geo here is a draw call, the floor is a draw call,
this other piece of geo number four is a draw call number five. But as soon as you introduce
a new material, that becomes a new draw call. So the materials and the geometry are to be
considered. And each one, if you have too many or not optimized, you're not been using material
instances or merging when you can, you can end up having a really huge scene, which has a lot of
draw calls, and that's going to hit your frames. So think of it this way, if you don't do that,
if you don't merge geometry, if you don't optimize what materials you're using, if you don't do those
things, you can imagine it such as a single image copying a single one gig file versus copying one
million KB files. It's going to eat up time. It's going to processing. You want to be able to work
efficiently. And again, consider your materials, dumb down your textures as things in the distance,
merge geometry, which is, which you can find is okay to do so. It's not maybe something that
doesn't animate. It's not interactive. You don't have to interact with. So you have to think
deterministically. And that's with games as well as film. So let's take a look at what's being
processed here. And we're going to be using a console command called stat unit. Stat unit works
really well. This allows us to see our frame, a total time to finish each frame, our game information,
C++ and blueprint game play operations, our draw CPU render time and GPU render time. Now we've added
a few since this particular graphic, this gives you an overhead of some of the main things you'll
be looking at, for the most part. But there are some others, as you can see off to the right,
because this once you run this console command, it will show up to your right towards the top.
And you'll see a few others in here, such as our dinariz draws, prims, as well as a newer one called
our HIT. So let's actually break these down our hit. So frame number shows you the total time
your hardware took to render that particular frame. Game thread, this is a C++ as mentioned
earlier, blueprint physics and etc. Draw thread CPU render time GPU render time for GPU, R hit R,
you can just think of it R is easiest for me. Typically it's RHI thread time is synced to the
frame, and it will likely be similar to the frame time. And then RHI stands for render hardware
interface, if you're wondering. Next, we have the dinariz. It's not supported unless turned on.
This helps to optimize things, especially if testing packaging out. So you can actually turn it on if
you need to, and if you need to cater a particular export that you need to send things to and say,
hey, I want to see what things look like on Windows and on a Android pad or whatever, I figure with
their interfaces for Android. They have their own interface, which is Android. My bad. So sad that
I said that. Such a PC guy and a Mac dude. So we have a prims here, the current amount of triangles
being drawn. So all these things are set into place to be able to help you look at your calculations.
So to better understand how that works, I have a graphic here that shows you the CPU game, game
context. And then next we have the CPU mostly draw what to render. And finally the GPU brings all
these two guys together and gives you our final pixel. So you can kind of think of it that way.
And have another graphic up here, which kind of breaks that down just the same to make it a little
bit easier to understand. So in other words, the game threat computes the data in the world
to know where everything is. The draw thread calculates what is on screen and then what can be
called. And the GPU thread is set to draw calls for any meshes that were not called by the draw
threat. So the bottleneck you can hit long thread times can create bottlenecks and reduce frame
rates. So if you have stuff that's unnecessary, that you were bogged down, you're saying this is
the thing you have to think about if you're coming from a movie background where you're
throwing everything at Maya, unreal, you have to be deterministic. You can't throw this chicken
and the chicken, the kitchen sink at it, because you want to be able to think what is it that you
need? What are the hero objects? What is the primary focus? And you have to come in with a game plan
and focus on making the higher resolution, the higher poly for those items and things in the
background can take a hit in the texture department. You can merge when you need to, nobody's interacting
with it. And this also goes for games. You just got to think deterministically how you're going
to approach things. So you can think of the calling this way. You can see here that it's only
unreal, only draws what's in front of it as where that camera is moving. It's not going to, it doesn't
draw everything at the same time. It's just an efficient way for Unreal to work. Now there are
different calling methods and you can turn these in and you can use a calling distance volume if you
want to. And we're going to go briefly over that, not too much in the film department. You don't use
it as much and Unreal works pretty well without necessarily needing it, but there will be times
where you might need it on a more game centric workflow. We see here we have the view frustrum
calling uses the visible screen area of the camera field of view FOV to call objects not within this
space. Professtrum is a Pyramedal, I got to get that word right, Pyramedal shape that includes
endear and far clipping plane, which defines the closest and farthest of any object should be visible
within this space. All not to be, all not in view removed. So it's basically kind of, let me go back
to the last slide we talked about. It's again only going to draw what's in front of that camera or
that view. Even as you are working in the editor, if you're just using a perspective camera, it's
going to do the same thing, which is super convenient to work with. All right, so there's
precomputed visibility. Now all these things you can actually adjust in your settings if you need to,
and that can be helpful in the cases of lower level hardware. So let's go on to the next one here.
There's dynamic occlusion, dynamic occlusion system is what Unreal is primary working with right now
in Unreal 4 and 5 and comes with several calling methods to choose from. So again, you can query
these, you can change these. I prefer using the defaults. I really will rarely ever have to mess
with these because Unreal just does a really good job and really relies on you to be efficient
with the way that you are making and creating and crafting your scene. So just think efficiency,
just think hero objects are the ones that get the most texture, they get the most polycount,
they get the most love in your scene and everything from there can degrade and be lesser.
Now we all know that directors, we all know that game heads will actually want those things to
change on the fly, just be prepared to swap them out if needed to prevent bloat. But for the most
part, if there's a game plan, a game level design, if there's a game plan for the film, knowing what
the objectives are, you're going to be working pretty nicely with the system in place. You can
see here kind of how it works and how the camera frustrum is shown here and you can actually see
it. Now this in previous versions of Unreal doesn't always show up to the party. So if you find in
5.3 doesn't quite show up, don't worry about it. It's just a demonstration of what that view is
as it increases. I found in earlier versions of Unreal this wouldn't always show up and wouldn't
always update as you changed that frustrum. So we're going to go and take a look at some
profiling, some quick tools to be able to profile and see what's going on in your scene.
This includes the profile GPU. Let's go to Unreal to see that up close and I'll point out a few
things. So in Unreal, we're going to go and activate profile GPU. I'm going to hit enter.
You'll see it pop up. Mine kind of went off screen. Let me pull it over for you so you guys can take a
look. So what is happening here is Unreal's taking a snapshot just for a brief moment
of my scene and where I'm at. I do recommend if you are going to use this tool to make sure that you
create a bookmark of the areas that you want to analyze for that brief moment. This snapshot here
you can save if you need to and it will allow you to go in here and you can analyze each one of your
frames and see what might be giving you some trouble. The yellow areas are going to be where the
most trouble we're going to have. Now we don't have a lot of fog in here but if we had fog,
looks like I moved some things. If we had fog, it would be a bit or at least had it heavier.
That would be the bigger draw call or issue we may run into and I can do a quick search if I wanted
to in my scene for exponential height fog and I can see for that brief second what my millisecond
were giving me overall. You'll see that it took a snapshot here just a couple seconds here
and you can again how the bar works is it takes those scene elements and it gives you a computed
breakdown color coding where your trouble may be. So let's actually go and look at this a bit
closer in our slides and we're going to go and look at a few other ways to do profiling. Now again
you don't have to use this method. This is just one of many because it tells you right here
in our track here what duration, what milliseconds took up the most time to calculate and then
you can find out oh I can see where my issues may have occurred and in this case it's the
ray tracing dynamic update. We can open that up further and we can see where those issues may have
occurred. Now you can a clap scenes at any time but you'll notice then the build here is a ray
tracing dynamic geometry update here and this took up the most time. Basically we have a lot of
geo in here so if we needed to we could do a bit more merging if we needed and even use some cards
for some of our land items they don't have to be full on nanite geometry. All right let's go back
into the slides. So again the profile GPU command allows you to quickly identify the GPU cost of
the various passes sometimes down to the draw calls. The data is based on GPU time stamps and is
usually quite accurate. Certain optimizations can make the numbers less reliable and it is good to
be critical about any number. So in other words I wouldn't just use it by itself it's great for a
quick look where the trouble's at but you definitely want to look at such things as insights and a
few other things I'm going to show you to analyze things overall. Drivers tend to optimize shader
cost a few seconds after using the shader. This can be noticeable and it might be useful to wait a bit
or measure another time to get more confidence. So again the snapshot is a disadvantage here
because you might want to compare a couple of snapshots together to see what you're getting
and this is why I emphasize maybe using other ones on top of this because it's good for a quick
look but necessarily not necessarily for a deep dive on what's going on. So overall how to use it
we again we placed the camera we made sure that we bookmarked it we ran GPU a profile GPU we typed
that in the command line and it gives us a snapshot of what's going on and again good to bookmark like
I mentioned before. Floating your cursor over the largest of the recorded bars shows you what is
taking up the most hits again this larger bar here and it looks like it's going to be our fog.
I did say the color before it's mainly the larger bar versus the color
and in this case it's the volume metrics so in this case it definitely is hitting a bit more.
As you can see you can do a comparable as I move around you can see our our sections are seconds
here milliseconds and you'll see that 1.15 in this particular case is eating up the most time.
And again clicking on it gives you the duration time to the process listed below.
So let's go ahead and take a look at another one called stat GPU. This is going to give us a nice
overview gives us like an overlay and milliseconds showing us what's eating up most of our GPU processing
time and calculation and it will give us the minutes the min the max and the overall average
and then you can actually get a quick real-time response and see what is going on. Now you can
run the stat stat space GPU or you can simply go to stats advanced and you'll go all the way down
to GPU here on the bottom. Let's go and take a look at it in Unreal.
So I'm going to go to my Alpalog. I'm going to type in stat space GPU. Sometimes it might take a
little bit of time to come up. You can now see here it is calculating for us letting us know what's
eating up the most of our time. We have our space probes there just sitting there waiting for our
information. As we move around you can test and see what those calculations are. Pretty nice to be
able to have that. You can say oh you know what I am noticing that things are a little bit heavier
here when it comes to our Lumen scene probe gathering. I think a little bit heavier here
when it comes to our volumetric clouds maybe a bit. So that gives you a quick rundown of things.
So I go to my output log here. I'm going to hit my up arrow and we're going to turn that sucker off
and it's simply just inputting that one more time and I'll just then enter. There we go.
That's it with this one. In the next video we're going to take a look at CPU draw threads and we're
going to look at Unreal Insights. Thanks again.